[Music]
continue
i can see somebody
okay so this is our welcoming committee
[Music]
did you see him he blessed himself
[Music]
five years ago almost no one had heard
of it
today it's a household name
in the us fentanyl is helping drive
overdose deaths to record highs it's
wiping out a generation
while in mexico it's disrupting the drug
trade in ways not seen in generations
but few people understand how the
cartels are getting their hands on the
chemicals necessary to make fentanyl
or what the fallout will be if they
continue to churn these raw ingredients
into more deadly
[Music]
from mexico's cartel country to the
border and into american communities
i'm going deep inside the fentanyl
pipeline to see exactly how it's fueling
the most devastating drug epidemic in
u.s history
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
cardiac
arrest
okay
like many first responders across new
england the manchester fire department
handles far more overdoses than fires
so it says it's a 26 year old female
overdose
not conscious turning blue
new hampshire has one of the highest
rates of opioid related deaths in the
country looks like we're the first ones
here
the chief is in there trying to revive
this patient
i got to see inside there was a woman on
the floor it was an
overdose she was overdosing
heroin make him
bent in our wheelchair
they took him from us
i first reported on fentanyl in 2015
when most americans had never even heard
of the drug
what i witnessed was shocking
and this is what they're finding in a
lot of these overdose sites fentanyl is
50 times stronger than heroin and killed
20 000 people the following year
today the situation is even worse
it's like playing russian roulette with
a completely loaded gun you're going to
die and it could be the first time you
pulled the trigger but every chamber is
full and how you know you want to take a
90 chance that you're gonna succumb to
that in seconds or minutes
that is mind-boggling
yo
come on
what do you think needs to happen for
this time certainly less drugs on the
streets right
in the united states that doesn't solve
anything you don't think so
you just make more
they're not stopping they're not slowing
down it's a national crisis
to understand why fentanyl is more
prolific potent and killing more people
than ever i have to go to the source
the mexican cartels
it's go time
contact sent us a location of where to
meet them it's at a port on a coast
close by it's about 20 minutes away from
where we are right now
fentanyl is the most dangerous drug in
america
and much of it comes from right here in
sinaloa mexico
hey guys what's happening
they need to deliver the package quickly
so my head's up that we need to be with
the cameras ready since
oh my god okay we're trying to get there
as fast as possible we've been in town
less than 24 hours and already my cartel
contact has gotten us a lead on the
arrival of a new shipment so that's one
of the things you know when you're
following a real shipment and supply of
drugs is that they're not going to wait
around for us before they it goes to the
next location
just crossing our fingers and hoping
that nothing falls through
there are two ways fentanyl illegally
enters the united states through black
market mail orders from china or via
mexico's drug cartels the people i'm
trying to meet their contacts they're
here
with a black shirt and the straw hat
yeah so it's uh
that's him right there
they don't want us to show their faces
or anything so just be careful
that this is our guy
okay now camera's down so he doesn't see
a camera's first thing
from
our hope for access comes through
my sources inside the sinaloa cartel
have agreed to show me the critical
first step in their fentanyl pipeline
so they've got this boat ready for us to
go out on sea with them
under the pretense of filming a little
fishing expedition
we're actually heading out to film
something that has never ever been
filmed before
we're being taken out to see by a guy
he's asked us specifically not to even
point the camera in his direction he
doesn't want to be filmed at all
and supposedly
we hear that our contacts will be
waiting for us somewhere out at sea
and then we'll be told what the plan is
fentanyl has been called mexico's ghost
drug
because nobody has any idea how much is
being produced and imported into the
united states
but what's beyond a shred of doubt is
its impact
hey
opioids are now the number one cause of
accidental deaths in the u.s killing
more people than guns or car crashes
yeah let's lay it down flat every layer
down flat okay in just a few years
fentanyl has become the most popular
synthetic opioid on the streets and
mexico's cartels have stepped up to
supply this demand
but it's a little-known secret that the
cartels can't make the drug themselves
they first need to source these potent
chemicals from somewhere or someone else
there's a boat that i think might be the
people we're meeting
this boat right ahead with uh
three or four guys inside
there are cargo ships all around us
there's a fishing boat right here
and then we see it
a row of large plastic barrels floating
towards the small tourist boat we've
been following
barrels that have been tossed from the
stern of a rust-covered fishing trawler
nearby there were about 10 barrels white
barrels that were thrown out to see
packed inside are the potent chemicals
the cartels need to create fentanyl
i mean it's so crazy
you look at it and it just looks like a
totally normal
fishing boat there's hundreds if not
thousands of them around the coast of
mexico in a way it's sort of the perfect
rhyme because it's so indistinguishable
it would never raise any alarm
okay it has to be really quick so it has
to be really quick guys they're saying
that they don't feel obviously safe here
what's inside the barrel
foreign
wow so they're saying that it was one of
these big cargo ships that we see all
around us that threw these barrels
oversea then the fishing boat over here
got a gps location where to pick them up
picks them up brings it up and then
there's a meeting point here where these
guys come and pick it up and then take
it off to land
mazatlan is one of mexico's busiest
pacific ports and while most of these
international container ships are moving
legitimate commercial goods the
smugglers tell me that some of the
people on board are in business with the
sinaloa cartel
delivering the chemicals they need from
asia or europe
okay
see okay they say they have to go
because there's the marines all around
us they're worried
we should definitely keep our distance
because we have a boat packed with drugs
and if the marines come or anything we
don't want to be seen being part of this
operation you know
incredibly one of the cartel's most
dangerous drugs
is being trafficked in plain sight
you can see what's happening right
behind me there unloading the boat one
barrel at a time going to shore
we're in a little port surrounded by
other fishing boats
there's actually a tourist a boat with
about 50 people heading out right now
right next to us
earlier i'd ask my contact if we could
follow this shipment from start to
finish
the answer was yes if we can keep up
we're here we're here we're coming up
okay quick
yeah
are they here on the left
was
loaded from the boat to here in a matter
of
15 seconds i mean it was crazy the whole
thing took about
10 seconds i don't know
we've been waiting and planning this for
months and months
or just like that one
oh it's like a tourist car yes just like
that
oh wow so it's these cars that you see
all around mazatlan which are these open
trucks with these benches on the side
and they transport tourists around here
it's sort of these local tourist taxis
and that's where they load it and that's
where they loaded everything
[Music]
mazatlan is a popular resort town and it
seems like the drug smugglers here are
using this to their advantage
none of the tourists appear to realize
that this is a key staging wall for the
cartel's grooming sentinel
[Music]
keeping a low profile is key to a
trafficker's survival
mexican law enforcement is all over the
city
and they're just one of many threats
[Music]
so why what's happening why are we
rushing
back
my team has reestablished contact with
the smugglers
but now it seems we're not the only ones
pursuing the shipments
as soon as they saw us they made a quick
have time to close u-turn door
really
we have to kill off very quickly
our local contacts here say that uh
difficulty
i'm hardly surprised mexico is being
ripped apart by gun violence
as a dozen different cartels vie to
control the drug trade
with 11 containers full of drugs i'm
sure that there's a lot of eyes out
there of other people trying to get
their hands on it it's worth a lot of
money
of course if we can't lose the people
following us my contacts are going to
disappear
along with the fentanyl shipment i'm
trying to catch up with
[Music]
let's just wait here for a second and
see if by any chance we see them pass by
us
i'm pursuing a group of fentanyl
smugglers through downtown mazatlan
but it now appears someone else is
pursuing me
it could be the sinaloa cartel
it could be a rival group or it could be
nothing
reporting on narcos in mexico can make
you paranoid
okay so it looks like we've lost them
they're not behind those
[Music]
it's a relief but it's also slowed us
down
we need to catch up with the shipment
we're following
we've been given access to film where
they put these barrels with the sentinel
precursors before they ship them to the
labs
but we're just waiting for an exact
location
okay i think this is it
the gps coordinates take us on a
30-minute drive outside of town to a
gated apartment complex
okay here they are down
i think we should put cameras down guys
sorry but
the most important shot right now is
inside
[Music]
we have to be careful not to reveal the
location or identities of our hosts
we're just following him our contact
these apartments are called privates
quiet residential communities my contact
tells me this private is controlled by
the cartel
the apartment is being used as a stash
house
a temporary weigh station where the
product is safe from cops and
competitors and it's managed by these
two men
venerable
[Music]
you can hear it it's uh
all liquid inside
they say the chemicals swishing around
inside these barrels will be transported
to secret labs further inland
where the cartels chemists will process
them into fentanyl itself
all this stuff that they have here is
worth about 350 000
and they're saying that once it actually
gets mixed with the other products and
transformed into fentanyl that it's
worth millions and millions of dollars
i've heard the cartels are getting
medical grade pharmaceuticals from
outside mexico
oh
pushing further will put these guys in a
tough spot with their bosses
since they won't let me open the
packages i can't implicate a specific
country or company
today president xi and i discuss
ways we can stop the lethal flow of
poisonous
drugs into our countries a special
emphasis will be placed
on the new phenomena
fentanyl
it's a well-known fact that china has
thousands of poorly regulated chemical
companies pumping out generic drugs and
pharmaceutical ingredients every week
i really wish i could see what's written
inside
okay
personality
trafficking networks are
compartmentalized by design
you get something from one guy and pass
it along to someone else
in between you do your job and you ask
few questions
but this network is nothing if not
efficient
my sources tell me it takes as little as
eight days for the chemicals to move
from a pacific ocean delivery to hidden
cartel labs then north across the us
border and finally onto america's
streets
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
fentanyl was first created in belgium in
1960
it was designed for use in surgery and
to treat the most severe forms of pain
over time american pharmaceutical
companies found a profitable way to
market related opioid medications
outside hospital settings since i've
been on this new pain medication i have
not missed one day of work and my boss
really appreciates that prescription
surged and patients were reassured that
the risk of addiction was low less than
one percent of patients taking opioids
actually become addicted
they were very wrong as fatal overdoses
skyrocketed doctors made prescription
opioids harder to get
addicts turned to heroin and the crisis
got worse
then in 2015 fentanyl emerged on the
black market in a big way
potent cheap and readily available on
the streets without a prescription
in the u.s overdose rates exploded to
record highs
but here in mexico fentanyl became a
boon to the underworld economy
[Music]
[Applause]
which is why i've journeyed inland
to witness how the cartels transformed
the precursor chemicals into
street-ready drugs
[Music]
it's happening tonight in an underground
lab
where we'll get a glimpse into the
future of the mexican drug trade
mother
[Music]
unlike heroin cocaine or marijuana
fentanyl doesn't need farmland or water
or sunshine it can all be made in an
underworld lab like this by a handful of
cartel chemists
so this is saying is the base to create
the pills the m30 pills the uh mexican
oxy
m30 pills are imprinted with an m on one
side and the number 30 on the other
in an attempt to make them
indistinguishable from legitimate
oxycodone pills
[Music]
in just the last four years millions of
these cartel manufactured pills have
flooded america's streets
we're saying just this little amount
here if you were to ingest this somehow
this amount could kill you immediately
that's how powerful this stuff is
okay everybody we should put the masks
on this is where it starts getting
dangerous here
if these chemists combine the raw
materials just right in a matter of
hours they'll have successfully
completed the next step in the process
creating sellable black market fentanyl
this is the pure fentanyl they mixed all
the liquids that come from
asia a lot of times from china we mix it
and they make this
is
[Music]
[Music]
like a veteran chef the chemist tells me
his mixtures aren't entirely based on
careful measurements but his own
physiological reactions to the chemical
process
i'm hoping really really hoping this guy
knows what he's doing here
i'm starting to think my team and i
should get the hell out of here outlaw
narco chemists accidentally kill
themselves all the time
in an underground lab with a cartel
chemist who's perfecting his latest
shipments of fentanyl
turns out he's a bit like a mexican
walter white
he runs a legitimate business by day but
for the past four years he's been
moonlighting for the sinaloa cartel
this is the pure fentanyl that they're
mixing with the wrath
once the paste dries and the room clears
of deadly fumes i'm told it's okay to
take off our masks
now that the chemical ingredients are
properly balanced it's time to craft the
fake m30 pills each one designed to
mimic the look of oxycontin the most
popular painkiller in america
it
[Music]
maybe
but that's not what i've seen on
america's streets
[Music]
it's clear that nothing is going to stop
the process tonight
and all that's left is to press the
paste into pills
the chemist tells me he makes a hundred
dollars for every 20 000 pills which
means that on any given night he can
make a few thousand dollars
[Music]
[Music]
me
a sense of dread follows minors
soon these pills will find their way
into the hands of american users
and we know what happens then
but down here among mexico's narco
traffickers
fentanyl isn't a deadly opioid
it's an opportunity
the ugly truth is that fentanyl supports
an incredibly lucrative underworld
economy
that means jobs for cartel accountants
couriers and chemists
and for those who undertake one of the
most dangerous roles in the pipeline
prepping the drugs for the final
crossing into the united states
just south of the u.s mexican border
i've been granted access to film with
the so-called packers
but we have to move fast they're
scheduled to smuggle another fentanyl
load across tonight
so they just sent us a location
looks like it's about seven miles from
the u.s border
it definitely looks like we enter the
rough part of town
so let's just be discreet
we're here this is it
[Music]
foreign
foreign
our hosts are tense for good reason
right now they're in possession of five
kilos of fentanyl
that's worth millions of dollars on the
streets of america
whoa
they tell me there are cops and
competitors everywhere in mexico many
willing to kill to corner the fentanyl
marketplace
using ordinary household ingredients
these packers will make five kilos of
fentanyl invisible to the eyes of the
law and i'm about to see how it's done
i'm seven miles south of the u.s mexico
border
about to witness how the sinaloa cartel
smuggles five kilos of fentanyl into the
united states
despite the green light i've been given
the packers prepping the shipment are
extremely anxious
so he's trying he's talking and uh i can
see this guy's getting really nervous
and telling him to speed up because he
says the person that's gonna take it
across the border is arriving any moment
and he wants to make sure that he can
get all of this out of this house as
soon as possible
he's putting coffee on it right now
i'm watching a shadowy game of cat and
mouse
in less than an hour these drugs are
headed to the most frequently crossed
and one of the most heavily patrolled
borders in the world
last year u.s customs and border
protection seized more than a ton of
fentanyl
and yet these packers plan on foiling
thousands of highly trained agents and
billions of dollars of surveillance
technology with little more than
homemade ingenuity
he has other products here he has
mustard
he has eso kiss what's
and all this is to avoid any sort of
smell
so crazy
coffee fabric softener and mustard
there's simply no way to describe the
smell but the one thing it doesn't smell
like
is drugs
layer after layer
every coat could mean the difference
between failure and profit
but dogs aren't the only concern
so now they were able to disguise a
smell
for the dogs
and also for the x-ray machines they
have this carbon paper around it
[Applause]
the packers tell me they'll make two
thousand dollars for their work tonight
four hundred dollars per package
and just like everyone i've met on this
journey
they do their job and then they pass the
drugs on to the next link in the supply
chain the girl he's referring to is
tonight's driver
in the trafficking world she's called a
drug new but i'll call her beatrice
beatrice tells me she's been doing this
for a year
and makes three thousand dollars for
crossing
per kilo asset
come on
[Music]
foreign
is
after we finish speaking beatrice agrees
to let me follow her to the border
the car part in front that's where all
the drugs are stashed
all ready to go up
to the us
and i think she's about to leave
fentanyl trafficking convictions in the
u.s have increased by nearly 5 000
over the past six years and those who
are caught are almost always sentenced
to prison
right now beatrice has five kilos of it
hidden in her trunk
is she going
something's wrong
[Music]
oh my god
she's seriously being followed by the
police i'm not even joking
right
[Music]
yeah
oh my god lord what did we do
i don't think we should go too close
and we need to figure out what the plan
is now
we were following her for
i mean 10 seconds and suddenly we see a
police car come out of nowhere
what the why what happened
just two miles south of the u.s mexico
border the drug mule i've been tracking
is pulled over by police
her trunk is filled with five kilos of
phantom
worth millions of dollars on the street
when she was stopped by the police over
there
i assume beatriz is busted
but the cops never open her trunk
and minutes later she drives off
i catch up with her further down the
road
documents
beatrice is shaken so she decides to
stay the night
but the following day
she's at it again
[Music]
and i'm not far behind
she has to be
super nervous you know
she's
you know packing five kilos of uh
fentanyl
so it's a very strange feeling because
on the one hand we've met her and you
don't want her to get caught and i'm
actually nervous for her but on the
other hand she has a car packed with
drugs that can kill a lot of people in
the u.s
it's complicated i know beatrice has a
growing family to provide for
but in all my years reporting on the
opioid crisis
it's the parents who lost sons and
daughters to overdoses that i remember
the most
come on
and i can't help but wonder what they
might think as i watch beatrice attempt
to carry a deadly shipment across the
border
but this is how a majority of drugs are
smuggled into the u.s according to the
dea
through legal ports of entry on the
southwest border stashed in passenger
vehicles or tractor trailers
and i'm here to witness it for myself
she's stopped she's being checked right
now
i would say just put the cameras
entirely down
last night i watched the cartel packers
slather her cargo in coffee mustard and
fabric softener all to avoid detection
by america's drug sniffing dogs
as the canine units approach i'm about
to see if their method actually works so
they're opening the trunk right now
they're looking under the hood
yeah
this is
a really uncomfortable moment
and then
just when i'm certain she's busted
oh my god
they're letting her go
yeah she's just going into her car and
leaving
i can't believe it
they just let her go i can't believe it
beatrice agrees to meet up with us a few
miles north of the border
i'm just going to talk to her she's
right here
[Music]
i cannot
despite how nerve-wracking crossing the
border was beatrice tells me she doesn't
think she'll ever go to prison
[Music]
oh
while there's no way for me to confirm
this
it's well documented that part of the
sinaloa cartel strategy is to infiltrate
and corrupt america's border agents with
lucrative
and there she goes
five kilos of fentanyl
when we contacted cbp for comments they
told us quote u.s customs and border
protection seized over 750 000 pounds of
illegal narcotics in 2019
our officers remain relentless and are
always working to stay one step ahead of
the cartels
but with so much demand for drugs and so
much money to be made it's a difficult
task
in recent years there have been almost
200 drug overdose deaths in the us every
single day
and fentanyl is the major reason
i'm eager to follow this road to the end
to expose just how easy it is for these
traffickers
but i'm also aware the shipment i'm
tracking might end up killing someone
so we were just given this uh location
right next to the 710 freeway here in
los angeles it's at the end of a
dead-end street
and i think that's uh
i think that's actually the woman
with the drugs inside her car
there's a guy in an orange jumpsuit with
a mask
so it looks like that's uh
where they're doing the deal right here
out in the open
the masked men tell me they're all
native angelinos
american citizens who work directly for
the sinaloa cartel
but like everyone else i've met they
focus on their jobs and ask no questions
do you know what's in the spectacle
you really don't care what you're trying
to do
got to keep on doing it
so can you tell me more or less where
they're heading oklahoma texas atlanta
this is one of the main distribution
areas that we have here
there is a high res getting out there
that's the reason why soon as we get it
has to get out real quick
[Music]
this is very much like a hot potato
where they just want to get it out as
soon as possible but it was incredible
because you saw she arrived and within
under 10 minutes they had managed to
take the drugs out of her carpet in
their car and then they're off
he says he does this every other week
which is
crazy
stay with me stay with me stay with me
never have so many people been addicted
to such a deadly narcotic
never has the need for solutions been
more urgent
i worry that the fentanyl supply chain
seems too big to fail
too many people benefit
and i've met many of them along my
journey
from the chemical companies in asia to
the cartels chemists
americans will have to find a way to
slow the demand
because the suppliers will always find a
faster and more profitable way
to deliver the goods
in fact they tell me the cartels have
begun to do just that
by eliminating their asian suppliers
if that's true the worst may be yet to
come for america's opioid epidemic
foreign
[Music]
you